you know him as a jackass a wild boy and
a party boy but how much do you really
know about chris pontius this is the
untold truth of the jackass forever star
big brother is to jackass what the
national lampoon magazine is to its
better known film classics like
caddyshack animal house and vacation the
subversive skate magazine was run by
people like eventual jackass ringmaster
jeff tremaine and videographer spike
jones and it brought together the west
coast half of the original core jackass
crew johnny knoxville shot himself with
a gun for a big brother article jason
weyman acuna worked there and chris
pontius was first interviewed by the
magazine in 1992 as a young skater who
quickly became so much more than just a
one-time featured figure pontius would
go on to write for the magazine for a
while his talents obviously extended
beyond his skating career since he even
starred in some of the publications
movies which were full-on proto-jackass
extravaganzas he eventually ended up
getting fired by big brother but you
know how the story worked out from there
when the magazine's video team started
looking at making a show for mtv his
former colleagues decided that he had a
little special something they were
looking for that thing being a
willingness to parade around the world
in a thong for the sake of comedy
as chris pontius told the hollywood
reporter he was nude and in big brother
before he was even 18. although this
would technically be against the law
somehow no legal hammers came down from
day one though pontius felt comfortable
being in as little clothes as possible
in front of the camera pontius's first
big character was named party boy a
rambunctious herald of good times who
would enter a place tear off his clothes
and dance around in skimpy underwear the
show was on mtv so he couldn't go own
natural but he got about as close as he
could to the audience's delight there
was even a jackass kit in which the
self-starter stuntman posed for a nude
photo shoot with the ambition of getting
into the pages of playgirl on a show
where everybody hurts themself in a very
real way it's a testament to pontius's
natural charisma that he was able to
keep people entertained and make a name
for himself simply by taking off his
clothes
you might think the idea of porch
pirating stealing packages off of
somebody else's porch is a jackass thing
but you'd be wrong the crew hurt
themselves but never anybody else and
would never consider it funny to steal
from the average homeowner and given how
hardcore these guys are they'd
definitely be the wrong ones to target
especially the savage chris pontius he
recently landed in the news when footage
from his front door caught a guy
stealing a package off his porch that
was meant for his wife as the guy walked
off with the box pontius ran out the
door and took off after him he then
posted the footage to his instagram and
made a big report he was prescient
enough to catch footage of the guy's car
and info on his way out which is pretty
impressive it sounds like pontius didn't
manage to find the guy though because if
he had there probably would have been a
fight
it's tough to imagine chris pontius the
constantly smiling and laughing member
of the jackass family being a fighter
but apparently he knows how to scrap in
an october 2020 interview on stevo's
podcast pontius detailed a few of his
fights he explains how occasionally his
friends would start a fight only to
leave him holding the bag and having to
take on eight guys at once growing up
fist fighting seemed like a really
important thing to
to be able to do in a famous jackass
skit where he dresses as the devil and
campaigns to keep god out of california
a passerby punches him and pontius is
completely unfazed apparently there was
even a situation where pontius and stevo
passed out eggs to an audience and told
them to launch them at the band electric
6. the band didn't appreciate it and
allegedly threw a beer at stevo and his
date pontius then put on a wrestling
singlet and ran to their trailer
challenging them to a fight when the
band continued hiding in their trailer
he punched in a window until security
came
there's a pretty legendary episode of
mtv's cribs in which chris pontius tours
the audience around his house at toyota
tacoma it has to be at the top of the
list of all-time hilarious crib segments
as pontius walks the camera through the
vehicle eventually exploring the bed
where he goes through all his g-strings
and costumes van halen headband 1984. in
his interview on stevo's podcast pontius
discusses the fact that he was traveling
so much back then and always had so many
couches he could sleep on that he was
homeless by choice stevo reveals that he
was too but he gave up the life before
pontius did so how long did chris
essentially live out of a toyota tacoma
according to party boy himself he was
homeless for eight years we saved a lot
i mean i i know i yeah we saved a lot of
money on rent and and just i mean
there was no reason to have a residence
wild boys is a nature show unlike any
other combining the appreciation of wild
animals with the type of insane stunts
that made pontius stevo and the jackass
crew famous from swimming with great
whites to playing with snakes it is
equal parts educational and extreme the
show is also the realization of one of
chris pontius's boyhood dreams as he
says in the stevo podcast pontius grew
up loving the series mutual of omaha's
wild kingdom he and stevo discussed how
they bonded during jackass and wanted to
do a project together so when the stunt
show ended they jeff tremaine and a few
other members of the jackass team
developed the idea of an animal show
done in a way only they could do it as
the hollywood reporter explains wild
boys also helped lead to the making of
jackass number two stevo told the outlet
knoxville joined us for a while
knoxville says have the dog bite me and
shoot me with a nine millimeter gun
while the dog's biting me and tremaine
says to knoxville hey whoa let's not do
this for mtv2 if you have that in you
let's make another movie
another great story pontius describes on
stevo's podcast is how he purposely
called out the wrong group for an award
at the 2003 european vmas pontia says he
kind of got talked into it though he
fully admits that he went through with
the prank because he thought it would be
funny when he opened the envelope to see
the winner was coldplay he first said
the winner was the white stripes as they
got up to receive their award pontius
then said he was kidding and it was
actually coldplay this incident is hard
to find a video of leading one online
commenter to suggest mtv edited it out
of subsequent replays on the podcast
pontius describes how his increased
celebrity and the responsibilities and
privileges that came with it were tough
to handle he describes another awards
show where he and stevo were given
amazing hotel rooms only for pontius to
get extremely drunk and end up passing
out naked on top of an suv outside
returning to the hotel in disgrace
despite all the crazy and many would say
immature stunts that make chris pontius
seem like the living embodiment of peter
pan he has in fact grown up pontius owns
a house has a wife and in 2019 he became
a dad as he announced on instagram on
december 14 2019 i am beyond excited to
announce the birth of my son axe magnus
pontius thank you everybody for your
kind words positivity and inspiration
for all these years shortly after stevo
posted a picture on facebook of himself
his longtime bromantic partner pontius
and acts in a loving embrace stevo wrote
chris is going to be a really great dad
and axe is going to be a very wild boy
given pontius's history of embracing
danger and at times living on a razor
edge the sharp name of axe is pretty
appropriate
in his podcast interview with chris
pontius stevo describes how pontius and
brandon decamillo were the two most
naturally funny guys in the crew joking
about how he always had to do gross and
painful stunts while pontius could carry
less dangerous bits thanks solely to his
sense of humor in fact pontius's sense
of humor and charisma are strong enough
that he's one of the few jackass guys to
also have acted in a few feature roles
he appears as irish henchmen in 2003's
charlie's angels full throttle he plays
black randy the punk legend who started
an la punk label that released songs by
groups including the germs in the darby
crash biopic what we do is secret he
even has a major role in johnny
knoxville's 2018 film action point this
is especially poignant because again
it's proof that the jackass guys really
liked pontius enough to single him out
for inclusion in their personal projects
pontius has several other roles and
while he may forever be known primarily
as a wild boy and a jackass the skater
who became a writer who became a star
who became a dad has shown that
reinvention is just another weapon in
his arsenal
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
jackass are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you